Now again, of course, this is a bit debatable,
but I think you will all agree that this one
here is actually super easy to solve shortest path on,
because let's say you start here, this is your mail station where you start.
You go all the way here and then you have no other choice but to go here,
because you have to visit all those vertices, and then you go back.
so there's not really difficult choices that you have to make
when you solve shortest path for this one here.
Now this one here is a little bit harder.
Let's say it doesn't really matter where you start out
because for a tour you can start out at any point
because you have to come back to it anyway.
And let's say you start out here and then you go up here
and then you already have your first choice to make,
so do you go this way or do you go that way?
Well, probably you want to go that way, but actually
there are certain distances where you might want to go this way,
so you have to make a choice here.
Let's say we go this way, and here we have to make a choice again,
so do we go this way and back here or do we go this way and here?
So a little bit harder to solve because we have to make certain choices,
but still not quite as hard as this one over here,
which I would think is the hardest  because say we start out here,
oh, first choice to make, this way or that way, well, that way.
Oh, again, new choice, this way or that way, let's go that way.
So all the time we have to make choices, which city to visit next,
and this is really tough, so what does this have to do with what
I just call distance from triviality?
So what does with what I just call distance from triviality?
If I mark the vertices in each of the networks,
if I mark the vertices in each of the graphs
that has more than 2 neighbors,
then here we have just 1,
here we already have a couple of them,
and this one also although this one is fairly easy, but let's be consistent here,
and here I have a lot of them,
and I'll give you one additional graph, which looks something like this.
Now this has a bit fewer vertices, but that's not the point here.
The point is that this graph down here
doesn't have any vertices that I would color
because all vertices have exactly 2 neighbors,
and this here is what I would call a trivial instance for shortest path,
because you don't really have to make any choices where you want to go.
Here you also don't have to make any choices,
but what you see here is that the number of vertices that have more than 2 neighbors
actually is an indicator of how hard it is to solve
shortest tour on that respective graph.
If you have a few of these blue vertices here that have more than 2 neighbors,
then it's easier to solve shortest tour.
Now I cannot give you the precise algorithm for this here
because actually that is a bit more complicated to figure out
and doesn't only have to do with these vertices here,
but I think you get the intuition
that we could try to use the number of these blue vertices
or some additional structural information as a parameter,
and it turns out that if you do this the right way,
then shortest tour is somewhat fixed-parameter tractable.